I think most people understand that life is
special, but it’s not always clear what
makes life special and different from non-life
such as stars, planets and rocks.
So we believe that what makes life so different
from these things is its persistence over
eons.
For example, some of the genes that we carry,
written in our DNA, have been around for billions
of years — some of them almost unchanged.
The way that is possible is because that information
and how to do certain things, how to build
these bodies, is written in an alphabet.
This alphabet for DNA is known to be nucleic
acids, but we believe that that’s not a
universal property of all life.
The only property that’s universal is the
fact that there is information written in
an alphabet.
You can use alphabets from any kinds of different
chemicals and other planets somewhere in the
universe where there’s life, we might find
this same phenomenon of persistence, but written
with information in a different alphabet so
that the universality of life is its persistent
engendered by information encoded in an alphabet
that allows us to transmit the information
from generation to generation for eons to
come.